مدمن صدام ، سأقوم
بإجراء هذا العرض التقديمي باللغة الإنجليزية
وأود أن أبدأ بالقول إنني فخور جدًا
بأنني فخور جدًا بهؤلاء الرجال الذين
يعشقون هاملت ، والفريق الذي
يشرفني حقًا أنني ألهمني هذا
عمل جيد ، هذه مهمة صعبة ،
ولا يتم القيام بها بسهولة ، وأنت حقًا
مثال رائع لما أحاول
توضيحه اليوم وما أحاول أن
أنقله اليوم هذا هو التأثير الحقيقي
وجزء المطر الذي كنت رائعًا فيه  إن شاء
الله للخروج من هذا ووضع
أنفسنا كنماذج يحتذى بها ولكننا انتشروا
بسرعة كبيرة كنت أشاهد محمد حفاس وهو
يغرد كل شيء عنك الآن وكنت
سعيدًا جدًا وهو بقدر
ما أنا ونتحدث عن القائد
في  أي قطاع خاص
أو هل يمكنك مساعدتي في
لعب هذا الدرس اليوم
سأتحدث عن كيفية احتواء مهنة الفرد
حيث يكون أنثى أو ذكرًا
على التصرف وتحويل المجتمع
وكيف يمكنك القيام بذلك أنت كفرد
كيف يمكنك أن تنظر إلى حياتك المهنية على أنها
رحلة ورحلة  التي تنشر
التعلم والتعاون وجزءًا
عبر المجتمعات والمجتمعات وفي
عرض تقديمي احترافي للغاية
سيعرف بدون تفاصيل فنية ، لذا فإن
رحلتهم واعتبرتها أحمق
كرحلة ستتخرج قريبًا إن
شاء الله قد ينتهي الأمر ببعضكم كفنانين
آخرين هذا الفرد  الذي لعب للتو
على خشبة المسرح هو جزء فردي موهوب
من الصناعة الإبداعية وقد
يختار ذلك يومًا ما كمهنة
سواء تخرجت اليوم واخترت
مهنة كرجل أعمال داخلي كفنان
يذهب إلى التعليم العالي ولا شيء
من هذا أفضل من  الآخر
في نهاية اليوم ، انظر إليها
كمهنة لطيفة ،
يجب أن تكون رحلتك هي الرحلة الوحيدة في الحياة التي
لا يجب أن تخطط لها لإنهائها ، إنها
رحلة متطورة مع
التعلم المستمر والتطوير المستمر
سأحاول التلخيص  وأن أكون موجزًا
ا وأحاول أن أضع كل ذلك في إطار لو
ي الشامل ال
لاثة يعني أن الأشياء الثلاثة التي أريد أن
تحدث عن
ا  نطور الحمض النووي الخاص بك بحيث يكون الحمض النووي الخاص بك في
مهنتك مرتبطًا بشكل أساسي بكونك
إنسانًا وما هي
قائمة التحقق لما أسميه
قائمة التحقق المهمة في تلك الرحلة ثم كيف
يمكنك رسم ما أسميه مجالات
التعلم والتعاون  المجتمعات
بناءً على معرفتك بناءً على
مهنتك بناءً على خبرتك
وخبراتك التي طورتها
بمرور الوقت الأسبوع المقبل ، لذا فإن صنع
الحمض النووي لحياتك المهنية خمس خطوات الخطوة
الأولى تؤمن بما
تؤمن به في قضيتك يجب عليك
حدد الدورة التي يجب أن أفكر فيها ،
حدد ما هو الترميز الداخلي الخاص بك ،
ما الذي يناديك من داخلك ،
يجب أن يكون لديك هدف في الحياة والعودة إلى
المنزل وتحديد ما أعتقد
أننا سنجلس هنا اليوم.
قادة المستقبل أعتقد بقوة
ليلة الخميس هذه وأنتم هنا يا رفاق ،
هذا مدهش أن
ما تؤمنون به يمكن أن يكون أي
شيء وطالما أنك تشعر بالقوة حيال
ذلك ، يمكنك ربطه  وستكون
قادرًا على الوصول إلى شيء
مفيد للمجتمع بطريقة ما
طالما أنك لست شريرًا
جيدًا بجانب سمة أخرى يجب
أن تمتلكها فيك وهي
التواضع والصراع
المستمر والمستمر  المسامحة والجوع بالنسبة لي ،
لذلك لا شيء ، وإذا كنت تعلم أنه
فيك بالطبع ، فأنت تعلم أن الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
يتعاملون معك يتعلمون وأنت
متعلم ، فهناك أمل في أن تعرف
أنني لا أعرف ولكني أعتقد أنني
لا تعرف شيئًا وأنت تعرف كل
شيء ليس كل شيء آسف ، لكنك
تعلم ، آمل أن تتمكن من تعليمي لذلك
كل شخص هنا في هذه الغرفة لديه
شيء ليعلمه الآخر ، وإذا كان
لديك هذا الموقف ، فهناك
الكثير لتعرف أنك تعرفه  أقل من
العديد من الأشخاص من حولك
سيطورون شبكة من المعرفة التعليمية
وهذا ما
أتحدث عنه لاحقًا في الرحلة
الأسبوع المقبل أيضًا قم بأداء واجبك المدرسي وأنا
لا أتحدث عن
واجباتك المدرسية ، قم بمدرستك  الواجبات المنزلية بالطبع ، كل ما
لا يعطيك هذا الأمر يجب أن تقوم به
ولكن هنا والسياق هنا
هو أن تقوم بأداء واجبك المنزلي هو أن تكون حكيماً أن تفعل أشياء
بامتياز تفعل الأشياء
بنظرة شاملة للحياة ما هو
تفكيرك المنهجي عندما تفعل
شيئًا كيف تفعل ذلك  فكر في
سلسلتين أخريين آخرين في عملك في سلسلة التوريد الخاصة بك ،
ما هي سلسلة القيمة الصحيحة الجيدة
وكيف تبدو من
هم مورديك وكيف
سيتأثرون بقراراتك
من هم أصحاب المصلحة ومن هم أصحاب المصلحة
وكيف يسير المجتمع  أن
تتأثر بقراراتك الشاملة ، قم بأداء
واجباتك المدرسية وثق بالآخرين ، ويسمح له
شخص مثقل بالواجبات المنزلية الجيدة في
الحياة بأن يكون
جديراً بالثقة ويسمح له بأن يكون شخصًا موثوقًا به
للآخرين.
الاحترام
وسأقول أنه باللغة العربية وقد علمني
قيمتان مهمتان ليس لهما ابن ذو
شذوذ ليس له ابن لا يعني أنه
سيكون شخصًا غبيًا يمكن
للجميع  n فقط قم بتلويح أي شيء عبرك
وستصدقه عندما
تثق به لا هذا لأنك
تفوقت وقمت بالعمل والواجب المنزلي
بامتياز حتى لا
يمر شيء من جانبك أو
يمر من خلالك وستتصل وستفعل ذلك.
كن شخصًا غبيًا خارج قرارات المقالة
ولكن ليس لديه ابن لذلك يمكنك
الوثوق به في الأسبوع المقبل وهذا يقودنا إلى
السمة التالية التي
تُعرف بالعلامة التجارية المعروفة للاختبارات وهذا
هو هذا مبني على سابقتي
أو  رقم ثلاثة الثقة في كل شخص
يستمع إلى روستون ، فكل شخص لا
يثق جيدًا في كل شخص لديه سبب وجيه ،
يكون لديه بعض الثقة في الآخرين
ويجعل الناس يثقون بك والجديد يمكن أن يصبحوا
جديرين بالثقة في تداولاتك مع
مشترياتك مما يقودنا إلى
النقطة التالية
دائمًا  شاكرة لذلك أقول أولاً شكرًا
لك راسل ومحمد هؤلاء الرجال ، لقد
كان لي شرف وتشرف بتدريبهم
في مسيرتي المهنية السابقة عندما كنت
في جيتا وكنت متطوعًا في
البرنامج في  الجرار وهم حقًا
أفراد موهوبون حقًا وأشكركم على
منحي هذا الشرف اليوم وما
زلت أشكركم على أي شخص وما
زلت يجب أن تكون ممتنًا
لأي شخص فعل شيئًا أظهر
لك شيئًا ما
شاركه في المعرفة أي شيء  أنك تشعر
بأنك تتشبث دائمًا حتى لا تتردد ،
كن شاكراً ولا تتردد في السؤال
بقدر ما أنت ممتن بقدر ما
لديك الحق في أن
تسأل ما دمت لا تعرف أنه استمر في السؤال
بعد
ذلك من فضلك ، فهذه
هي الأشياء التي ستعمل على
بناء الحمض النووي الخاص بك كمحترف
مهني وأيًا كانت الوظيفة التي ترغب في متابعتها
وهذه الأشياء هي التجارة
التي ستجعلك تعمل كمغناطيس مع
الآخرين  لن
يجعلك ذلك لن يمنحك مهارات ولن
يمنحك موهبة ولن
يمنحك أي شيء باستثناء كونك
متعاطفًا كشخص لا يستطيع تخيل
ذلك ، يمكنك التواصل مع الآخرين  الأشخاص
الذين يمكنهم استكشاف الحياة والذين يمكنهم استكشاف
المعرفة ومن ثم يسمح لك
ببدء رحلتك المهنية ، لذا ما
يهم حقًا في الرحلة الأكثر نحافة
سمع عن نسخة ريتشارد برانسون
مالك الرئيس التنفيذي رئيس مجلس الإدارة لا أعرف ما
هو على حق  الآن الإصدار ولكن الإصدار هو
منحة مذنب وكتب نظرة عدوانية إلى حد ما
على هذا الرجل والأمر كله
يتعلق بمن التقينا به الآن ما أحاول
قوله هنا هو الاستفادة من من
تقابله اليوم لا أعتقد أن الجميع يعرف
كل شخص في الغرفة  آمل
ألا يكون ذلك لأننا سنخطط لذلك
كمجموعة وقد أتينا للتو إلى هناك للبيع
كنت تقابل أشخاصًا جدد اليوم التقيت
بأشخاص جدد اليوم وأود أن
أستمر في بناء هذه العلاقات
معهم ومع هؤلاء الأشخاص في الواقع
ذاهب إلى حفظي لقد فاتني
هذه النقطة إلى
جانبي التالي ، لكن من تقابله هذا
مهم لأن كل شخص تقابله
يمكن أن يكون لديه شيء ذو قيمة كبيرة
أو منفعة مشتركة أو مصلحة مشتركة
قد تكون لديك ومن ثم
ستؤدي هذه العلاقة إلى شيء
مثمر للغاية ، لذا اقرأ أيضًا
youtube أو شاهده أو افعل مع كل
التحدي الذي تعرفه يمنحك معلومات أو
يقدم لك معلومات ، ولكن عندما
تفعل ذلك ، يجب عليك دائمًا ربطه
بشيء  ستستفيدون
من لقضيتك ، لذلك كان لدينا سبب
وحددنا هدفنا ، لذلك في بعض
الأحيان كل يوم في حياتنا اليومية عندما
نعترف بالإيكونوميست
نريد أن نقرأ الموضة التي ستقرأها عن
الفن ولكن في بعض الأحيان
بدافع الفضول والتوسل من أجل
القراءة ، تأكد من أنه يمكنك أخذ
الأشياء الخاصة بك وأنت تقرأها وتمييزها ،
اربطها وربطها
بقضيتك هذه الأشياء طوال الوقت إذا قمت
بتوثيقها وإذا قمت بجمعها
ودمجها ، لن تصدق
ما يمكن أن ينتظرك هذا المشروع
بمرور الوقت ، فما قرأته
قبل عامين وتم تسليط الضوء
عليه لأنه يؤدي إلى دورة
تفكر فيها اليوم بعد 100 لتر  تبدو وكأنك
قد سلطت الضوء على أن لديك
مشروعًا فجأة عندما تكون خطة
العمل بسبب قراءتك تتم في
النقاط البارزة التي مررت بها في الأيام المقبلة
، وبعد ذلك ستجلب لك الثروة أن تجعل
الناس في إن شاء الله وأولئك الأشخاص
الذين هم من أنت  لقد التقيت وأنت
أثناء الانتظار وأرادوا الاستماع
وأردت ربطها بقضيتك التي
تريد ربطها بأوراقك التي
تريد ربطها بمهنتك ، فأنت
تقيم العلاقة بين قراءاتك
وكل ما تحدثنا
عنه هو  محظوظ بالنسبة لك وعليك
أن تنظر إلى
ثروته ثم ابحث عن الأشخاص
الذين يستمعون ولكننا استمعنا
إليك وعدنا إليك الذين هم في الواقع في
نفس خط قضيتك ، ما ستفعله
بعد ذلك يتم منحك افتراضيًا.
الفضيلة الافتراضية هي في
الأساس امتياز الروح المعنوية
وأنه في حياتك المهنية عندما تكون لديك هذه
الفضيلة ، ستبدأ في رؤية
النداء الكمي الذي يمثل قفزة نوعية في الامتياز ولكن
انتظر  الفضيلة آسف لا
تنتظر الفضيلة ، انتظر الثروة ،
لذا فإن انتظار الثروة لا يعني
مجرد انتظارها ، فهذا يعني
أنك تبذل الكثير من الجهد ،
فقط انتظرها الآن التكتيكات
التي تفعلها  من أجل بناء تلك
الفضيلة وبناء شبكتك
وتحدثنا عنها ولكن عليك أن تكون
مبتكرًا في بناء شبكة الآن
لدينا قادة من القطاع الخاص إذا
طرقت أبوابهم ، فسيقول طلابنا
لا ،
لن يذهبوا  لقول لا ، إنهم يرغبون في
الترحيب بك بشدة بقلوب منفتحة ،
لذلك يجب أن يكون لديك شبكة من
الأشخاص في مجال الأعمال التجارية تحتاج إلى وجودها في
مجتمع الأعمال في وحدة القيادة
، وعندما تصبح شيئًا إن
شاء الله ، فأنت جاهز لدراسة شيء ما
ما زلت بحاجة إلى شبكة
واتصالات وعلاقات مع
الشباب ، حافظ على
علاقتك مفتوحة مستحقاتك.
المزيد من الأمثلة كانت للحكومة
علاقة سابقة والمدارس لديها
علاقة مع مدرستك
بأكثر علاقتنا معك ، ابحث كثيرًا
عن دمى المجتمع ولدينا شبكة
من الأشخاص ، وشبكة من الأشخاص الذين
نشاركهم في هذه الجيوب
دائمًا حافظ على هذه العلاقة مفتوحة باستمرار.
لم نقطع هذا الجسر أبدًا ،
ولكن قبل أن أقول أو أتحدث عن
جمال الفشل ، سأخبرك عن سبب ذلك
لأنه في يوم من الأيام
ستؤدي جيوب العلاقات الشبكية إلى
مجالات التعلم والمجتمعات التعاونية
وسأعطيك
التكتيك وفي الجزء الأخير من هذا
العرض حول كيفية القيام بذلك ولكن
قبل أن أقول هذا آسف لقد غادرت
قبل الجليد قبل أن أقول إنني أريد اثنين
منك أن تفشل ، سيكون أفضل
شيء سيحدث لك في
الحياة إذا كانت خاصة إذا كانت في
مراحل مبكرة تفشل وتفشل مرة أخرى ، ولكن عندما
تفعل ذلك وعندما تفشل ، تعلم
التحدث عما فشلت
فيه ، فقم بتدوين ما الذي تعلمته  الدروس
المستفادة ما هي تجربة التعلم
من هذا الفشل ثم
الفشل مرة أخرى على سبيل المثال في العمل هو ماجستير في إدارة الأعمال
إذا فشلت ثم
تلتقط نفسك وتذهب وتقول بفخر إنني
فشلت بشكل جميل ، افتخر
بها وفشلت مرة أخرى  الآن أراهن بحياتي على
أي شيء لم يفشل أي منهم من
رواد الأعمال الداخليين الذين
حققوا نجاحًا كبيرًا اليوم في
مشروع ولم يفشل في العملية
ولم يفشل في أي أو
أي من معالمهم ولدينا
رجل أعمال هنا اليوم و  أعتقد أنك
ستتحدث عن هذا أيضًا ،
لكنهم لن يفشلوا حتى يجربوه ،
لذا فالثلاثة هي قدرتنا التي
يجب ألا تكون عليها ، ولا يجب أن تشاركها
ولا تتردد في الفشل الأسبوع المقبل ، حسنًا ،
لقد تحدثت عن قائمة المراجعة
والرحلة التي تحدثنا فيها عن حمضك النووي ، ما
الذي تحتاجه حتى يكون لديك ضيق يمهد
موقفك قبل أن تبدأ
مسيرتك المهنية والآن وصلت إلى
مستويات في حياتك المهنية حيث يمكنك
الجلوس والقول إنني على دراية
لقد كنت محظوظًا كثيرًا ، لقد
طورت فضائل ، ما هو التالي أعني
أنه الآن لديك
التزام بالتزامك تجاه مجتمعك
وثق بي إذا كنت تفكر بشكل واقعي
وتواصلت مع مجتمعك
وستفعل ذلك  كسبب باعتباره
علامة فارقة في حياتك المهنية ،
ستنجح من نقطة البداية في حياتك
المهنية ، فكيف نفعل ذلك بعد ذلك من فضلك
في الشبكات التي أنشأتها ،
لديك شبكات مع مراكز
مجتمعية مع مجتمع عملك مع مجتمع ضخم مع
مجتمع الصناعة الإبداعية ولأنهم يثقون
بك وبفضل الفضيلة الأولى ، يمكنهم
مشاركة Billikens المشتركة
معك وهم لا يعرفون بعضهم البعض
بالطريقة التي تعرفهم بها جميعًا لأنهم
في شبكات مختلفة الآن يمكنك
الاستفادة من الحكومة ولكن  قبل
أن تفعل ذلك ، تروج لقضيتك ، لديك
لأن لديك هدفًا تحدث عنه
بشكل غير مباشر وكل تجمع في كل
تجمعات مجتمعية تحصل على
مواهبك  k حول ما هو هدفك في الحياة
، وفي يوم من الأيام في تلك المجتمعات ،
سيشاهد شخص ما قدرات الدمى هذه ،
لدي رأي مشترك مثلك
وأنت تضرب هذا الشخص بشخص آخر
لديه هذا العمل المشترك ،
لذا تحدثت عن هذا أنت  خدمة
المنفعة المشتركة في الأسبوع التالي
وما يحدث ، وجدت فجأة شخصًا ما في
منظمة خيرية مجتمعية لم
يسمع عن هذا القائد في
القطاع الخاص ، سأعطيك مثالًا فعليًا
لإعادته إلى الحياة
مؤخرًا.  ورشة عمل مع
الأميرة البندي ، وهي قائدة كبيرة من ماشاء الله
، وهي تدير
مؤسسة موثوقة تجعل أساسًا
متينًا هو مؤسسة تقدم
الأموال والمنح للمؤسسات الخيرية
للقيام بمبادرات الآن هي
تريد الانخراط مع القطاع الخاص
الذي رتبت لها لها  معها لحضور
ورشة عمل مع قادة القطاع
الخاص وتخمين من أتى ماكدونالد يهتم بشيعة
تعجبني أستطيع أن أشرب مشروبات أمير وما
إلى ذلك
في صناعات مختلفة تمامًا هنا
، ثم المنظمات غير الحكومية ونقاط البيع
منظمة أخرى مجتمع Margit أو أي
منظمات غير حكومية مختلفة ذات منافع
مختلفة وأهداف مختلفة ، لكن خمن ماذا في
نهاية ورشة العمل وكان الجميع
يقدمون عرضًا تقديميًا مدته خمس دقائق
لأنني أثق  في قضية الجميع
وذلك عندما قمت باختيارهم / قمت
باختيارهم عن قصد ، لقد رأوا جميعًا
شيئًا ما في بعضهم البعض ، لذلك لدينا اليوم
ماكدونو يتحدث بعيدًا ، هل لدينا
ماكدونو يتحدث إلى ايكيا وموسيقى الروك AR
مهتمة حقًا باللغة العربية
وتعلم حل التعلم الإلكتروني وهكذا  on و
المنظمات غير الحكومية مرتبطة أيضًا بهؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
لديهم منافع مشتركة ، تم إنشاء انقسام في مجتمع جديد
من أشخاص
لم يعرفوا بعضهم البعض أبدًا ولم يعرفوا أبدًا أن
لديهم فوائد مشتركة ، ويمكنك
ترك نقطة الاتصال وهذا الرابط
بحيث يحدث ذلك مرة واحدة ولكن  عليك أن تفعل ذلك
مرة أخرى مع مجموعات مختلفة ، لذا قم بذلك مرة أخرى
بعد ذلك يمكنك الجلوس
والاستمتاع ببرنامج لماذا  لقد أنشأت
تأثيرًا متسلسلًا الآن ، كلما فعلت
ذلك أكثر ، كلما استطعت الجلوس ، لكن ما
مدى راحتك ، لذا يمكنك الجلوس
بشكل مريح وأنت تبني المزيد من تلك
المجتمعات التي لا أعرف ما إذا كنت أوصلها
بشكل صحيح وواضح ولكن  النقطة المهمة
هنا وما أحاول
تقديمه هو أنك في داخلك أنت بالتأكيد
شخص هاجمك ، فأنت بالتأكيد
شخص لديه مهارة ،
وستكون شيئًا ما إذا وجدت
دورتك التدريبية وكانت هناك عملية لنشرها
التي تذهب وتنتظر حتى تغادر وتجعلها
عارية في حياتك المهنية ، حدد
هدفًا في حياتك المهنية لنشره في
مجتمعك ، ولكن بعد أن تجلس
إلى الوراء وتستمتع بالقطعة التالية ،
ستطور أننا نذهب وحكمة
من فشلك.  ستفشل
هناك وستفشل
وتتعلم وثيقتك التي تعلمتها ، وستوفر عليك التحدث
إلى الآخرين ، وستكون شبكات
المجتمعات على الإطلاق ، وسيكون لديك
الكثير من الأشخاص من حولك يثقون
بك لأنك تمتلك  هذه الصفات
ستكون لديك الحكمة في مرحلة ما من حياتك
المهنية والمهم هو نشر
هذه الحكمة ولكنك تهجئها
لمن يستمعون إليها ولا يسمعونها
هي عدم الاستماع إذا استمع إليك شخص ما
وكان هناك كمستمع جيد.
له الحكمة التي عندك شكرا جزيلا